we are now 2011 it's really the time to
use the eye from the sky we can measure
things on the earth especially on
cropland from satellites my real
motivation is to start using this kind
of technology that can help feeding the
world we have to feed all these people
in the world the problem is the water
scarcity we really have to develop very
good information systems in the end what
counts is what happens in a particular
field that particular field has to
produce more with less water so if we
don't measure it's happening and if you
don't guide the local advisors and the
local farmers this is not going to
happen we invested a lot in space
technology all these systems are up and
running and we are not using them a
satellite can scan the earth can scan
the crop we can measure spectral
reflectance we can measure temperature
of the crop and the temperature tells
you very much whether the crop is
healthy satellite is reading the leaves
how much carbon is taken how much water
is used we call that P I mapping pixel
intelligence division of us is to make
smart pixels for smartphones millions of
people can start using that information
what it really means is that a farmer in
India can get that information on his
smartphone then that local firm in
Punjab will already convert it in
something like you should irrigate on
Tuesday and you should irrigate 40
millimetre which basically means should
open the gate for three hours
so the strengthen is that we combine
this smart measurements with the local
knowledge by using this technology and
my sending information to people in the
field we directly give them access to
information which i think is fundamental
to improve the world
you